Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Dino. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Wofür war noch gleich äh das Internet gedacht?
Da sind wir wieder. Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer achtundfünfzig, wa? Super, es äh wir schreiten äh voran. Rasant. Ja. Trotz alledem machen wir auch Fehler.
Ja, Fehler äh ähm ja, ich glaube, wir haben.
Nicht richtige totale Fehler.
Es ist kein Fehler.
Wir mal, ich würde sagen, Wahrheitsschwankungen. Wir unterliegen gewissen Wahrheitsschwankungen und das ist ja eigentlich auch normal, das kennt ja eigentlich auch jeder.
Ich würde ja sagen, der Fehler liegt beim Hörer, der äh wir wollten die Medienkompetenz des.
Wir sagen eigentlich nur die reine Wahrheit, aber irgendwie kommt's immer wieder falsch an. Ja.
Wir haben eure Medienkompetenz geprüft, ja? Dem dem Beispiel eines eines großen Bloggers folgend,
Ähm und ähm haben komm, komm zu dem Schluss, dass wir zur letzten Folge ein,
Einen Hinweis machen müssen.
Eine Erratung.
Die Auflösung zur Prüfung der Medien kommen,
Ähm also,
wenn wir in den Bundestag mit sechshundert noch was äh Leuten, die hier drin sind, uns darauf äh spezialisieren würden, die Krankheitszwelle auszunutzen als Opposition,
ähm dann würde das genau ein einziges Mal funktionieren und dann äh würden irgendwie,
die Parteien eventuell anfangen, vorher, weiß ich nicht, fünfzig Mann krank zu melden,
Ähm damit die anderen nur nur zehn hinschicken, um ihre Mehrheit dann irgendwie zu sichern. Und dann,
aber vielleicht doch mit zwanzig Spontan Genesenen dann anzutreten oder oder was auch immer. Also man kann die die Krankheits- oder oder oder Toskana-Reise bedingte Abwesenheit von Abgeordneten nicht ähm
nicht sinnvoll ausnutzen im Bundestag. Man möchte das ja eigentlich auch nicht. Ähm,
Unter der vor, also solange wir sagen, wir haben im Bundestag irgendwie diese diese Mehrheitsverhältnisse der Fraktion, da kann man ja stundenlang darüber diskutieren, ob man das jetzt gut findet oder nicht, dass es diese Fraktionsdisziplin gibt, aber solange,
Gegeben ist und so die Entscheidung im Bundestag gefällt werden, ist es nicht,
Nicht wirklich gangbar Krankheitsfälle durch oder Abwesenheiten auszunutzen. Wie wir es suggeriert hatten.
Auszudrücken äh wir kamen mit
These auf, die ich auch mal so kolportiert habe ohne viel drüber nachzudenken so, ja na ja, wären jetzt sozusagen alle anderen von der Opposition, bei der Abstimmung zum Leistungsschutzrecht äh da und dagegen äh gewesen, dann wäre es ja gar nicht durchgekommen, aber das ist natürlich.
Man so schön sagt, eine Milchmädchenrechnung, äh denn das ist einfach nicht die Realität des Bundestages und das wissen wir auch.
Das heißt, wir haben eigentlich wir wussten eigentlich, wie es wirklich ist und auch wenn wir was anderes gesagt haben.
Ne, wir haben ja den.
Das gar nicht gemeint.
Ich würde uns jetzt so gut erhalten, dass wir den Hinweis mit der Toskanareise und äh auf das Gespräch mit Konstanze, dass wir dem der Hörerin die Möglichkeit gegeben haben,
kleine Hinweise zu deuten, wie hier die Medienkompetenz oder.
Verteilt ist.
So, dann äh also die Verschwörungstheorie, dass äh die dass die Opposition jetzt sich gemütlich zurückgelegt hätte, um dann äh,
äh die Leute noch länger in der Netzhölle schmorren zu lassen, ist also äh eher äh in ins.
Lässt sich lässt sich nur bedingt aufrecht erhalten.
Lässt sich nur bedingt aufrecht erhalten. Unter der Bedingung. Wenn man also alle anderen Gegebenheiten ignoriert, dann könnte man das aufrecht erhalten diese These. Ähm.
Es gibt dann noch eine äh einen Blogpost, auf den äh ich von einem treuen Hörer hingewiesen wurde, der uns auch auf diesen Fehler hingewiesen hat. Vielen Dank nochmal darauf. Dafür. Ähm,
nämlich eine Liste, wo dann diese Leute waren. Da gibt's also dann so die, die also die fehlenden Leute. Ja, das äh,
ich suche mal gerade raus, wo der das war, der äh ach jetzt habe ich den Link hier noch gar nicht mehr. Also in dem Blog des Isa Matrosen,
findet man das, wo dann, wo dann alle waren und deren Reise alle auch relativ sinnvolle Entschuldigung. Ähm,
dann sei noch noch weiterhin zu dieser Verschwörungstheorie äh,
Angefügt, dass ich vor einigen Tagen mal einen Blick auf einen, auf den Entwurf des Regierungsprogramms der SPD werfen konnte,
in dem äh ich das Zitat finde, dazu müssen wir die Erprobung neuer Geschäftsmodelle auch rechtlich ermöglichen,
zum Beispiel durch eine vereinfachte Lizenzierung
Presseverleger brauchen eine gesetzliche Regelung, die ihnen die Verfügungsgewalt über ihre Produkte im Netz sichert und ermöglicht die unbefugte Verwendung ihrer Artikel durch Dritte, zum Beispiel durch Aggregatoren oder Harvester zu unterbinden
Das ist äh ganz klar ein Bekenntnis zum Leistungsschutzrecht.
Das würde ich auch sagen.
Im Entwurf des Regierungsprogramms der SPD.
So viel dazu. Es wird dich erstaunlich, wie stramm die alle stehen. Es ist echt äh haut mich wirklich um. Also ich kann mir ja auch nicht ernsthaft vorstellen, dass sie das wirklich glauben.
Ja, wie gesagt, also ne, also der Glaube an das geistige.
Ja, aber ich meine allein.
Auch Sozialdemokrat.
Ja gut, aber ja, aber dieser neusprech äh hier, ja, also
die Erprobung neuer Geschäftsmodelle muss rechtlich ermöglicht werden, indem wir sozusagen Regelungen schaffen, die alte Geschäftsmodelle schützen. Das ist einfach ja, schwarz ist weiß und äh unten ist oben. Das äh.
Ist äh würde man sagen, dass es ein altes Geschäftsmodell schützt. Ich weiß gar nicht, ich finde schon, dass ein Leistungsschutzrecht ein neues Geschäftsmodell ist, also diese ganze Abmahnkram und so. Ja klar, natürlich.
Okay, verstehe er so.
Also.
Mahnung sozusagen als Geschäftsmodellentwicklung, ja.
Ich würde das noch viel an, noch viel schlimmer, also die Idee, überhaupt ein Gesetz zu schaffen, welches ein Geschäftsmodell, also ein Gesetz zu machen, mit dem Ziel, ein Geschäftsmodell zu zu schaffen,
Das finde ich schon völlig also allein die Idee.
Wieso? Also ich meine, das äh das das mir jetzt ein bisschen zu allgemein gesagt, weil da könnte ich so das Erneuerbare-Energien-Gesetz auch mit reinziehen, das ist auch eine Gesetzesinitiative, die ein neues Geschäftsmodell äh schaffen soll, nämlich.
Nee, das ist aber nicht die Maxime, das, dieses, die, die Gesetz, das, die Maxime, äh neue erneuerbare Energien ist ja irgendwie Umweltschutz zu betreiben. Das wird ja.
Ja und äh ja und die Maxime dieses Gesetzes ist halt Verlagsschutz ähm.
Die Maxime dieses Gesetzes, laut der SPD ist es, neue Geschäftsmodelle rechtlich zu ermöglichen. Das steht da so.
Nicht irgendwas muss geschützt werden oder sonst was. Da steht dazu müssen wir die Erprobung neuer Geschäftsmodelle rechtlich ermöglichen. So wenn die besseren Grundhälften für das Gesetz, dann hätten sie den dahin geschrieben.
Na gut, wie auch immer. Wir stellen auf jeden Fall fest, äh von einer
einen mütigen Ablehnung des Leistungsschutzrechts Gedankens kann äh zumindest auf Basis des Studiums, des Regierungsprogramms äh der SPD äh nicht wirklich
die Rede sein hier liest sich das einfach mal ganz so, als ob man letztlich,
Wäre man schon in der Regierung auch nicht anders gehandelt hätte. Also hätten wir jetzt sozusagen rot schwarze Koalition, wie wir es ja schon auch hatten,
Dann wäre uns wahrscheinlich diese ganze äh Debatte ums Leistungsschutzrecht auch nicht erspart geblieben,
also so so liest sich das jetzt, ja? Also, ich meine, wenn das hier äh die Forderung ist, dann müssten sie ja im Prinzip dazu stimmen,
Dass sie jetzt dann im Bundesrat dann dagegen stimmen wollen, ist dann da auch schon wieder absurd. Also ich meine klar, dann kommt's rüber. Ja, aber die konkrete Ausführung und die Details und wenn wir das und das regeln und so weiter, naja gut. Ähm,
Ich denke,
Ihr Ratum ist hiermit äh abgeschlossen. Wir warten jetzt auch, wie's weitergeht mit dem Leistungsschutzrecht. Da gab's jetzt in dieser Woche nichts Neues, richtig? Also ich habe nichts gehört.
Aber dafür äh,
sind äh etwas äh ältere Geschäftsmodelle wieder in der äh Diskussion. Ja, es geht ja eigentlich irgendwie immer um Geschäfts äh Geschäftsmodelle, Geschäftsmodelle. Hier,
Ähm,
Ich habe das so ein bisschen nur am Rande mitbekommen, muss ich sagen. Ähm was ist denn da eigentlich los? Irgendjemand hat wieder was gegen Porno,
Auf EU-Ebene richtig.
Ja also das war ähm.
Es gab einen Bericht über den Abbau von Geschlechterstereotypen, der ähm,
in einem,
Ausschuss des EU Parlamentes da irgendwie oder der Kommission da irgendwie da sowas, so wie die immer irgendwelche Berichte haben, ja? Und da drin äh,
Fand sich also die Forderung nach einem umfassender umfassenden Verbot aller Arten von Pornografie in den Medien, ja,
ich ähm der wurde vorgelegt von,
Äh ach so genau, das war der Ausschuss für die Rechte der Frau und die Gleichstellung der Geschlechter. Und die Berichterstatterin war Tamara, Liu Tart. Ja, so und die hatten jetzt irgendwie ihren Bericht da.
Von den Linken.
Frau Lidl ist eine Linke, ja? Und die haben, genau, die haben also gesagt, ja, hier mach mal ähm,
verbieten wir mal alle Arten von Pornographie in den Medien
und bezieht sich da auf irgendwie eine europäische Entschließung von neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig gegen die Diskriminierung von Frauen in der Werbung. Äh und da ging es dann um die,
und ich denke da haben wir dann auch Thema, wo man sich durchaus mal mit auseinandersetzen kann,
Freizüge, mediale Darstellung der Frau in oder ja, der Frau kann man da wirklich so genau sagen, in in der Werbung, ja, also wie wie werden welches,
wird der Gesellschaft.
Wie Achs-Werbung.
Ja äh genau.
Sich irgendwie der Magen umdreht.
Diese sexistische Kackscheiße, wie man das so schön nennt, ja, äh der mal entgegenzutreten war das faire Ziel dieser äh äh dieses Berichtes und ähm ich denke, ist auch ein sinnvolles Ziel. Dann,
leider äh eben in der Verbindung mit diesem etwas komischen Satz, dass man also alle äh Pornographie in den aller aller Arten von Pornografien in Medien verbieten möchte,
wo das Problem wohl war, dass jetzt die Medien da nicht so klar definiert sind und sich die Furcht äh breit machte, dass damit eventuell die ähm.
Das Internet äh auch äh gemeint sein könnte. Ähm und das hat einen sehr großen ähm hat zu einem sehr großen Aufschrei geführt. Ähm es kümmerten sich dann alle eben um den,
um den ja und äh,
ganz viele ähm ganz viele äh Horrorszenarien, die da also äh Horrorszenarien, das Zensur, die dann da entfaltet wurden,
Ähm wobei diese Initiative oder dieser Bericht noch nicht einmal irgendwie eine gesetzgeberische äh Wirkung entfaltet hätte, ja? Ähm,
Also das war eher so wie so von vorneherein eine Luftnummer, die dann aber sehr groß gekocht wurde. Und zu allem Überfluss äh fing dann also es fingen dann Leute an,
E-Mails an ihre Parlamentsabgeordneten zu Europaparlamentsabgeordneten zu senden, indem sie ihn dann sagten, dass das diese Idee aus aus verschiedenen Gründen sehr, sehr dumm ist und dass das das Internet bedroht und ähm,
solche Sachen. Woraufhin dann ähm,
die Administratoren des E-Mail-Servers des EU-Parlaments einen Filter geschrieben haben oder einen Filter implementiert haben, der diese E-Mails blockt,
Nicht bloggt.
Welche E-Mails block.
Ich werd's in denen das Wort äh Genderstereotype vorkommt. Weil na ja, weil äh also Auslöser war wohl,
Auslöser war, dass vermut, also es scheint so gewesen zu sein, dass jemand ein äh da,
weil das Spamboard nicht äh kurz drauf geworfen hat auf das EU Parlament. Woraufhin dann da also irgendwie sehr, sehr viele E-Mails irgendwie bei einigen mehreren hundert Eingingen.
Mhm.
Und die unter Umständen wohl eventuell auch sehr gleichlautend waren. So so liest sich das ja. Ich habe die E-Mails ja nicht bekommen. Ähm,
Auf jeden Fall gab es auf einmal eine Maßenflut und die Administratoren äh haben das offensichtlich,
Interpretiert als eine,
ähm als einen Spamangriff oder also wie auch immer gearteten oder eine Mailbombe, ja? Ähm,
Ich äh,
Fun Fact. Ich äh glaube übrigens, dass der, dass ich erfolgreich nicht mehr in den Wikipedia Artikel Mailbombe vorkomme, deswegen könnten wir den sogar eventuell verlinken. Ich habe mich da mal bei der Wikipedia beschwert, weil ich da irgendwie bin
Ist eine andere Geschichte. Ähm also das äh die Administratorin der E-Mail-Server sahen also ähm eine Mailbombe,
und äh implementierten dann offensichtlich einen Filter,
Und dieser Filter war dann laut dem äh Piratenparteiabgeordneten,
Ähm wie heißt der noch gleich? Christian Ängste, der äh also für die Piratenpartei,
Aus Schweden, da in dem Europaparlament sitzt, der war dann nicht mehr in der Lage, überhaupt eine E-Mail an den an seinen äh Parlaments, Präsidenten oder was da zu schicken, indem das Wort Gendersterial vorkam
weil das eben von diesem.
Admins geblockt wurde. Oh Mann.
So, das heißt, es es wird diskutiert ähm Pornografie irgendwie zu ballen aus dem Internet und die das Internet,
oder eventuell auch aus dem Internet, das Internet,
Nutzt sich oder die Nutzer des Internets nutzen das Internets, um dem Europaparlamentsabgeordneten zu sagen, diese Idee finde ich nicht gut,
Und das Europaparlament blockt diese E-Mails.
Sehr schön, was solche Zensurmaßnahmen bewirken können, nämlich dass das auch die normale parlamentarische Arbeit da drunter leidet, wenn man jetzt anfängt, irgendwas rauszufiltern.
Also äh.
Wunderschön äh wunderschöne äh Geschichte, also wie kann man,
Ja, also eine insgesamt eine totale Luftnummer, weil also ich meine, was fällt denen auch ein,
Also so Filter aufm E-Mail-Server eines Parlamentes so, da würde ich den Praktikant nicht dran lassen. Ich ganz ehrlich, also,
Wie auch immer. Also.
Ja, ich hoffe nur, dass die Aalen um ihren Job haben und dieses dass sie auch wissen, damit umgehen können,
Das ist generell natürlich jetzt, ich meine, können wir ein dickes Fass aufmachen, das ist halt eine generelle Frage, ne. So, wer hat die Kontrolle äh über die Netze? Das sind ja nicht unbedingt dann immer nur,
Die Provider oder der Staat, sondern das ist manchmal auch die Administratoren und irgendwie richtiges Vertrauensverhältnis zu schaffen, ist für alle Organisationen eine Aufgabe,
Aber wir wollen ja jetzt nicht in irgendeine Richtung schießen, wir stellen einfach nur äh zur äh wir stellen einfach fest, da gab's eine äh äh Debatte, die vielleicht teilweise auch etwas falsch formuliert, falsch verstanden wurde. Das ist für mich jetzt noch nicht so richtig klar, was jetzt.
Irgendwie unklar war.
Richtung ist, äh es handelt sich hier jetzt auch nicht wirklich um irgendein großes äh große Gesetzesinitiative. Sie ist ja die Rede von einem Bericht oder einem Entwurf, der hier äh äh gemacht wurde,
im Rahmen eines Ausschusses und ich weiß nicht so ganz genau was jetzt hier eigentlich abgestimmt werden sollte, ist eine eine Entschließung,
Des europäischen Parlaments.
Sowas wie das am Ende steht denn da das Europäische Parlament steht fest, dass.
Es ist mehr so ein so eine Wunschfeststellung, sodass das ist, das wäre, was man gerne will, aber das ist jetzt nicht unmittelbar eine gesetzliche äh Regelung, die in irgendeiner Form bindend ist, sonst mehr so eine Meinungs ähm,
Bekundung. So, die ist aber jetzt auch so nicht gegeben hat, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Es gab dann äh die den Entschluss darüber und ähm der dieser äh,
Äh also dieser äh dieses dieser Bericht mit dem Pornographieverbot wurde irgendwie nicht angenommen und dann gab's noch einen äh zweiten Vorschlag, der da ebenfalls diskutiert wurde, äh
demzufolge Provider und sonstige Anbieter von online Diensten eine Selbstverpflichtung zum Reinhalten des Netzes,
über eine Gleichstellungscharter im digitalen Bereich äh hätten eingehen sollen. Also so,
auch irgendwie eine totale äh nicht so ähm.
Ja, zu Maja ist auch das.
Beide wurden auf jeden Fall irgendwie abgelehnt so, da sitzt irgendwie.
Konkrete Problem von äh,
sexualisierender Werbung, sexistischer Werbung findet auch primär jetzt derzeit auch noch gar nicht so unbedingt jetzt im Internet statt, sondern es vor allem erstmal so ein Werbebranche,
Problemen, was mit den derzeit populäreren noch populären Maßnahmen wie Plakatwerbung vor allem. Bei mir verbunden ist im Kopf.
Plakatwerbung ist auch immer noch das Massentauglichste.
Ja
Bill. Und vielleicht Fernsehwerbung noch. Na gut, dazu müssen wir jetzt, glaube ich, nicht weiter äh ausführen, oder?
Genau, also es ist, wie gesagt, Thema ist äh genauso schnell vom Tisch, wie es äh drauf kam und äh ja, diese Sache mit der E-Mail, mit den E-Mail-Sperren ist dann da noch die.
Also das Internet ist auch weiterhin vor Porn.
Internet ist vor Porn.
Aber da gibt's ja auch immer Feinde äh des Internets, die wollen das äh dann doch anders sehen.
Ja, es war mal wieder Welttag der Internetzensur und äh seit einigen Jahren äh gibt es da jedes Jahr einen Bericht von der Organisation Reporter ohne Grenzen,
Und die haben dieses Jahr den Fokus ihres,
zur Internetzensur auf die Überwachung gelegt. Ähm und nicht,
Also nicht direkt auf Zensur, sondern auf äh Überwachungsmethoden. Ich denke auch, wenn man jetzt wirklich mal in so einen autoritären äh Start denkt, dann ist natürlich Überwachung immer besser als,
Zensur, ja, also du kannst.
Durch Überwachung musst du am Ende eigentlich nicht mehr zensieren, weil du, weil die Leute wissen, dass sie überwacht werden und dann den, den Dingen eh fern bleiben, ne? Also.
Also besser im im Sinne der Logik eines äh.
Ja. Also nehmen wir.
Bösen Staates.
Oder in den man kann auch einen guten Start, sagen wir mal, äh in Deutschland ist doch immer die große Debatte, um das Buch mein Kampf,
ja? Äh von Adolf Hitler, was äh in Deutschland irgendwie nicht verlegt werden kann oder so, aber Deutschland bemüht sich darum, dass äh es nicht erhältlich ist, ja? Und da gibt's ja immer irgendwelche Probleme, wenn äh.
Das wird sich jetzt aber sehr bald ändern.
Genau, es wird sich irgendwie bald ändern. Ich bin ja gar nicht genau auf dem Laufenden, aber ähm,
Wenn man jetzt einfach sagen will, das Buch ist überall erhältlich. Man muss nur diesen Registr, man muss sich nur als Besitzer dieses Buches registrieren beim Kauf,
sage ich mal, das ist erhältlich, aber meldepflichtig, ja, der der Buchhändler muss da im Personalausweis nehmen und äh der Bundesregierung melden, dass du jetzt gerade meinen Kampf gekauft hast, ja, ähm das wäre ähm,
Eine Maßnahme, die sehr viel die die gleiche Wirkung hätte ohne einem den Vorwurf der Zensur einzuhandeln, ja?
Vielleicht ein ziemlich bescheutes Beispiel.
Ich bin auch grade etwas äh verwirrt.
Das ist das einzige, was mir einfällt, was in Deutschland als Veröffentlichung äh tatsächlich einem einem Regimehotel liegt, was man Zensur nennen könnte.
Gut, aber das war jetzt wohl nicht der der Fokus. Also zu meinem Kampf, äh du weißt ja, wann Hitler gestorben ist. Ja, das äh ist dann in zwei Jahren siebzig Jahre her, dann wird das Ding gemeinfrei. Es kann derzeit halt nur deshalb nicht veröffentlicht werden, weil,
bayerische, weil Bayern, als Land, sozusagen, die Rechte daran wahrnimmt und äh halt,
verhindert, dass es veröffentlicht wird, quasi auf Copyright-Basis und das läuft halt jetzt aus.
Ja und demnächst.
Und sie antworten da aber auch äh ganz interessant drauf, indem sie eben äh an einer kommentierten Fassung arbeiten. Genau. Ja. Und die wird dann erscheinen.
Mein Kampf, liebe Kinder ist, ist das wohl am meisten verkaufte und am wenigsten gelesene Buch direkt nach der Bibel, ne? Das musste man ja,
musste man damals haben. Das gehörte sich so, das musste im Bücherregal stehen, aber kein Mensch hat das mal gelesen. Das kann man auch gar nicht lesen.
Das ist auch wirklich albern.
Also ich ich habe das mal versucht, aber ein bisschen verrückt. Das Einzige, das hattet ihr doch, glaube ich, bei.
Gelesen im Rahmen einer künstlerischen Interpretation ist das ja dann sozusagen erlaubt.
War das nicht auch dieser Österreicher, der das da gab's nicht nur eine. Ja.
Da gab's nicht nur eine äh Aktion in der Hinsicht und äh Hinsicht und wenn man sich das anhört, da steht einfach das ist einfach der Typ ist einfach krank,
Da kann man nichts anderes sagen, ja, das ist und, und, und, und, das blöde ist eigentlich auch, dass durch diese durch diesen Verbot, durch dieses Verbot,
das Buch einfach aufgewertet wird in seiner Bedeutung, ja?
Das ist das Argument, was ich bringen wollte.
Na, da habe ich dir endlich zur Konklusion geholfen.
Ich danke dir, dass Sie aus dieser blöden rausgekommen bin.
Gell? Weil es ist schwierig, ne.
So ähm zurück zum zum Fokus äh dieses Jahr geht's also um Überwachung, Reporter ohne Grenzen, äh Geißeln, also Überwachung,
und sagen, okay, ähm was sie eigentlich immer machen ist, ähm sie kümmern sich um Staaten
Da gibt's auch immer äh haben wir in der Netzpolitik Redaktion hängen dann so ein schönes äh so eine Weltkarte, wo dann so die Pressefreiheit abgebildet ist oder sowas, solche, solche Sachen in der Art, gibt's dann immer. So und die sagen jetzt, also welche Länder sind die bösen Überwachungsländer, die
Zweitausenddreizehn ähm war rein. Da gab's also äh einen dramatischen Anstieg in Zensur und Überwachung in den letzten drei Jahren,
China, OK, braucht man nicht lange drüber diskutieren mit Ihrer und Ihrer massiven Zensur gehören die natürlich in jeden Bericht, über, über Zensur und Überwachung,
Iran, die ja ohnehin schon daran sind, äh daran arbeiten, irgendwie ihr eigenes Internet dazu haben und die Verbindung nach außen komplett zu kappen, die auch noch äh nochmal Thema dieser Sendung sein werden.
Internet. In unbestätigten Gerüchten soll es auch demnächst ein Internet geben.
Wo kommst du denn? Wie bekommst du denn auf die Idee?
Entschuldigung, ich mache nur Witze.
Okay, Syrien,
zentralisiert seine Internetinfrastruktur ebenso und zwar so sehr, dass sie der äh Regierung die Möglichkeit bieten, die Verbindung tatsächlich zu kappen,
und äh Vietnam, wo gerade die Blogsphäre starke Zensurüberwachung erfährt. Das ist also der äh das sind also die Länder,
und ähm erstmals haben die Reporter ohne Grenzen jetzt auch äh Firmen,
mit auf ihre Liste aufgenommen, nämlich die äh die die Überwachungs äh Tools, Hardware und Software herstellen,
Da gibt's mir äh die Firma,
Armesis oder Amesis, die kannte ich noch gar nicht so. Die hat ihr, also die Spyware Eagle nach Libyen verkauft, also sie haben einen,
Trojaner Libyen verkauft, Staatsreal Libyen. Ähm
Blue-Code äh ist bekannt. Äh die bauen äh die Package-Inspection-Geräte und die wurden in Wurma und Syrien festgestellt.
Ähm Gamma äh aus Deutschland, Großbritannien, war bei uns auch schon öfter Thema, die also den,
Staatstrojaner, Finn Fischer in Baraien und der Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate eingesetzt haben in Ägypten, angeboten haben und das auch in Deutschland gerade tun,
Ähm dann der große oder kleine Konkurrent von Gamma äh Hacking Team, Italiener, ähm die,
deren Staatstrojaner remote control System heißt und in Marokko und der Vereinigten Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate äh gefunden wurde.
Hacking Team.
Hacking Team, ja. Die haben, das sind die mit dem cooleren Namen. Es ist tatsächlich so, die machen genau das Gleiche wie Gamma,
aber weil sie net, ich mein Hacking Team ist natürlich echt 'n irgendwie 'n Firmenname, der irgendwie der klar geht,
also Sache jetzt mal als Hacker so. Ne, ne, die aber.
Was heißt denn, ich finde, der geht gerade mal nicht klar, weil ist ja nun wirklich frech.
Ja, aber das machen sie halt so, ne.
Naja, ich weiß, dass sie es machen. So ist es halt, aber ich finde den Namen total mega uncool, da finde ich Gamma, ehrlich gesagt.
Gamma ist, Gamma kann man besser an Staaten verkaufen wahrscheinlich so, wenn man.
Ja Haking Team klingt so wie fünfzehnjährige.
Hacking Team Punkt klingt so ein bisschen nach äh Punkt RU, ne?
Punkt RO.
Äh ja ähm Hacking Team, also wie gesagt, gleiche gleiche wie Gamma. Ähm,
Und äh Trophy-Chor, die wir auch schon äh besprochen hatten, Ex äh Nokia Siemens Deutschland äh äh Nokia Siemens,
die äh ebenfalls so äh Überwachungssysteme, die Package Inspection, Aggregatoren und so weiter äh herstellen und in,
mehr als hundert Ländern präsent haben, darunter bei Rhein und Syrien. Deren Verbreitung, wie gesagt, daran liegt, dass sie so schön mit der Nokia Siemens Hardware äh,
integriert. Ähm.
Das heißt, du weißt, wo die Leute sind und wo sie gerade rumlaufen und das alles in Echtzeit und kannst dann wirklich schön deine Kameras auch draufrichten und Pipapo. So wie man sich das irgendwie immer in so Filmen ausgemalt hat, wie es vielleicht mal sein könnte,
auch hin.
Man könnte dann zum Beispiel im Mobilfunknetz erkennen, wo es eine spontane ähm Zusammenrottung von Menschen zu geben scheint. Äh.
Die miteinander kommunizieren.
Ja oder die auch nicht miteinander kommunizieren, sondern einfach nur da sind und da solche solche Dinge macht äh bietet Troficor,
Nochmal kurze Zusammenfassung. Armes ist Frankreich. USA, Gamma, Deutschland und Großbritannien. Hacking Team Italien, Trophy Deutschland. Das sind die fünf Firmen, ja? Die kommen also alle aus den,
Aus den schönen westlichen ähm,
ja, ich sage jetzt mal, wenn jetzt Italien nicht dabei wäre, wenn jetzt Italien nicht dabei wäre, könnte man sagen, aus den, aus den Beispiel Demokratien oder so, ne, aber Italiens, freie Welt.
Altes Europa.
So nennt man das, altes Europa plus USA.
So und ähm Reporter ohne Grenzen verlangen,
Exportkontrollen, ja? Das ist also ihre große Forderung an die an die Regierung, also EU und USA,
Und äh interessant ist, wie haben jetzt diese Firmen darauf reagiert? Ja, da da ist also sehr geil ist die Reaktion von von armes, die sagen, ja ähm,
wir müssen jetzt sagen, also wir haben jetzt äh,
März zweitausenddreizehn, ja? Und der Bericht wird veröffentlicht und Armes ist da, ja Moment mal, äh diesen Geschäftsbereich, den ihr meint, den haben wir doch im November zweitausendzwölf verkauft,
Also seit guten seid guten vier, fünf Monaten gehört uns das doch gar nicht mehr. Wir sind schockiert, dass wir jetzt als feines Internet bezeichnet werden,
und betrachten das als Gegenstandslos, sagt also die Sprecherin.
Weil der betreffende Teil ja bereits verkauft wurde, dann ist man ja dann automatisch wieder weich äh äh reingewaschen.
Also zweitausendelf war dann bekannt geworden, dass das äh Programm von Amelsis zur Internetüberwachung in Libyen genutzt wurde,
Da gehörte ihnen das auch noch, aber sie sind schockiert, schockiert, ja,
Das mit aller äh Weise das jetzt zurück, ja? Gegenstandslos. Okay. Ähm,
Hacking Team stellt fest, ja, wir haben eine eine Führungsgruppe, die jeden verkauft, der Software bewertet und ihr Veto einlegen kann. Das ist sowas ähnliches wie die ähm
diese Ethikkommission, die bei Kammer irgendwann mal installiert werden soll, ja? Wir sprachen darüber. Ähm und da gab's noch einen auf der RSA-Konferenz letztes äh vor ein paar Wochen, einen schönen äh,
Fall, wo dann nämlich Jacob Applebaum,
Den CEO von ähm von Hacking Team irgendwie konfrontierte mit der äh mit dem moralischen Problem, dass sie ihre Software eben an zweifelhafte äh Organisationen äh und Regierungen geben.
Auf der Bühne oder was?
Ich ich meine eigentlich, dass äh Jack kommt nicht auf der Bühne war, sondern im Publikum oder so. Aber also er wurde also interessant ist, was dabei rauskommt,
der sagt, ähm dass sie auch kontrollieren, wie die Software eingesetzt wird. Das heißt, der der Typ von Hacking Team hat,
offen zugegeben oder den Eindruck erweckt, dass sie wiederum eine Vektor in ihrer Software haben.
Um die Regierung zu kontrollieren, was sie damit machen,
Ja, ähm ob das jetzt stimmt oder nicht, ist jetzt eigentlich erst mal egal.
Weil.
Weil damit haben sie sich auf jeden Fall für den deutschen Markt disqualifiziert, denn wenn du, sagen wir mal, diese ganze.
Nicht nur für den deutschen.
Ja, das.
Das stimmt noch mal dazu. Also Sie haben sich auf jeden Fall für alle, für alle, für jeden Markt quasi disqualifiziert mit dieser Äußerung. Und aber sie liefern quasi ein sie bestätigen einen wichtigen Punkt, der die Kritik an Staatstrojanen aus privater Quelle,
Ähm betrifft nämlich, dass ähm die Regierung,
So oder so auf jeden Fall ein Datenschutzrisiko eingehen würde, indem sie dieses ausspionieren outsourct.
Mhm. Mhm.
An andere Firmen, ja? Also das ist nochmal ein wichtiges Argument und das trifft ähm nach meinem Verständnis der Systeme ebenso auf ähm,
auf das auf die das Setup von Gamma zu ähm,
Soweit ich das richtig interpretiere, auch ähm die die Server ja selber unterhalten, an die ihr Tool dann reportet. Das heißt, sie geben nicht die Kontrolle,
aus der Hand, sondern liefern liefern und bereiten die Daten für die Regierung auf, ja? Also es ist tatsächlich ein,
Ein Hacking Team, was man da hat und selbst wenn man jetzt also sagt, man man unterstützt irgendwie diesen diesen Ansatz, der des Staatstrujaners, dann hat man da nochmal einen ganz riesiges Datenschutzproblem, das auf einmal private Unternehmen
an so einer invasiven Maßnahme.
Geil, oder? Ist irgendwie diese Firmensitzen sozusagen so eine so eine Spice Cloud auf.
Genau, ja, ja, ja, genau, das machen die, klar. Ja, ja, das ist, ja, ja, das ist eine Spike Cloud, ja. Also, da, das ist ungefähr.
Genau, ihre, ihr, ihre Überwachungsdaten in guten Händen,
Wir können zuverlässig sicherstellen, dass äh sämtliche Überwachungsmaßnahmen diskriminierenden äh Aktivitäten und Staatsbürgerdatensammlung bei uns einfach,
sicher sind.
Sie loggen sich einfach ein über.
Wir haben ja eine Vektor, da kann ja nichts passieren und äh.
Also mit dieser mit dieser Vektor, weißt du?
Ähm interessant ist, äh ob das, ob das jetzt stimmt oder ob er einfach nur äh den den Kritiker
Applebaum von der Backe haben wollte oder ob sie halt gar keine brauchen, dass sie jetzt eigentlich meine meine Verständnis
weil wenn sie eh so 'ne, wenn sie das eher als quasi Cloud-Service anbieten den Staaten, dann brauchen sie keine Vektor mehr, weil sie haben ja den Server auf dem die Daten gesammelt werden,
und von dem aus sie auch das System,
ihr ihr Trojanernetz da pflegen, updaten und so weiter, ne? Also ähm wichtiger oder interessanter Punkt, der dann nochmal angesprochen wird.
Ich würde an der Stelle ähm.
Den nahtlosen Anschluss zum zum nächsten Thema suchen.
Das ist nämlich die äh die Bestandsdatenauskunft,
Da haben wir in Lokbuch dreiundvierzig schon mal drüber berichtet und da geht's um den Paragraph hundertdreizehn des Telekommunikationsgesetzes,
Und da hatte eben, ich glaube, Ende Januar oder Anfang Februar äh das Bundesverfassungsgericht, die Regelungen zur Speicherung und Herausgabe von Nutzerdaten, Passwörtern und PIN Codes,
Ermittlungsbehörden als verfassungswidrig eingestuft.
Und die Praxis, wie das im Moment geregelt wird, die Bestandsdatenauskunft, ist noch längstens bis Ende Juni anwendbar. Das heißt, ähm.
Äh der die Regierung muss sich jetzt bemühen, da mal ein neues Gesetz einzubringen, was die Bestandsdatenauskunft angeht. Äh wenn ich sage Februar, meine ich, Februar zweitausendzwölf, nicht zweitausenddreizehn,
Im Oktober letzten Jahres wurde dann dieser Gesetzesentwurf beschlossen, da hatten wir dann auch darüber berichtet und ähm das Interessante an diesem Gesetzesentwurf war oder das die Hauptkritikpunkt war, dass die Bedarfsträger ähm,
In dem Fall dann Bundeskriminalamt Bundespolizei Zoll Zollfahndung, Verfassungsschutz, Bundesnachrichtendienst und militärischer Abschirmdienst äh ohne Richtervorbehalt Zugriff auf diese Bestandsdaten,
Sollen, mit denen, mit deren Hilfe sie dann auch zum Beispiel IP-Adressen, Zunahmen auflösen können. Ähm.
Das Ganze in Form so einer AP,
Ja, also das ist einfach quasi äh wie bei so einer wie wie heißt das denn, Kraftfahrtbundesamt oder was, wo die wissen, wo man auflöst, quasi ein Kennzeichen zu einer, zu einem Fahrzeughalter, ja? Sowas wollen die halt haben,
für für die Ermittlungsbehörden oder für die für die genannten äh für die genannten Organe
Und ähm wie gesagt, ohne also offen, also möglichst einfach automatisiert, sodass sie einfach gucken können. Da gibt's keinen Richter mehr dazwischen, da muss kein Antrag mehr geschrieben werden, sondern da wird halt die IP-Adresse eingegeben und dann wird steht da der Anschluss
inhaber offen, aufm Bildschirm und möglicherweise noch weitere Daten,
Wie gesagt, irgendwelche PIN-Codes und so ein komischer Kram, aber das ist irgendwie ist immer noch ein bisschen unklar. Und da gab es jetzt eine äh Anhörung der Sachverständigen im Innenausschuss des Bundestags,
dessen Vorsitzer der gute Wolfgang Bosbach hat. Es war auch nochmal so ein Kapitel für sich. Er war dann irgendwie ein
Rechtsanwalt, ein äh äh Professor äh der Berliner Beauftragte für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit Alexander Dicks
jemand von der Hochschule der Polizei, Peter Scharr, der Bundesbeauftragte für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit
dann noch irgendwie einer von der Universität und jemand vom LKA.
Und dann wurde mal so zusammengefasst, was an diesem schönen Gesetzesentwurf so äh.
Wurde das denn irgendwie gestreamt als Aufzeichnung bereitgestellt oder beziehst du dich jetzt nur auf ein Protokoll?
Nee, das äh ich meine, dass äh ja, ich habe einen Link auf die auf das Video davon, ja. Ich würde nur gerne mal die die Kritik nochmal zusammenfassen.
Ähm und zwar äh klar, ne, wir wenn wir von solchen Daten Zugriffsmöglichkeiten ohne Richtervorbehalt reden, dann sind wir ganz, ganz,
ganz klar im nah an der Kante der der unserer Grundrechte und der,
Grundgesetzes in Deutschland und so. Ähm,
und also ein Kritikpunkt ist hier, dass sie diese Bestandsdatenauskunft in keiner Form limitieren wollen auf,
eine Gefahr oder einen Verdacht, ja, ähm und also keine Beschränkungen auf den Einzelfall, sondern einfach die grundsätzliche Möglichkeit haben wollen, die abzurufen, ähm,
ähm und dass dadurch natürlich weiterhin dann, wenn.
Man zu diesen Bestandsdaten auch irgendwie Zugangssicherungscodes zählt, äh dass sie die halt auch einfach bekommen könnten. Und ähm,
Dass das also erstmal so gar nicht gehen sollte ohne Richter Vorbehalt und das weiterhin gefordert wird, dass,
man als Bürger wenigstens darüber benachrichtigt wird, wenn eine solche Abfrage stattgefunden hat, ne?
Die AP ja auch machen, wenn sie schon den Leuten rausgewächer IP-Adresse ich zu welchem Zeitpunkt hatte, könnte sie ja automatisch triggern, dass mir auch noch direkt eine E-Mail zugesendet wird, die Adresse haben sie ja, äh wo dann drinsteht, übrigens
dann und dann ähm hat irgendwie äh,
von der Kripo Münster irgendwie mal kurz geguckt, äh welche IP sie gerade haben.
Und dann kommt natürlich der Herr vom BKA, der ernst wird und sagt,
dass ähm der Entwurf besonders toll ist, weil er nicht mit Formvorschriften überfrachtet ist und so ein Richtervorbehalt würde die Ermittler immer nur viel Zeit kosten.
Ja, interessanterweise hat der Mann auf eine gewisse Art und Weise recht, denn der Richtervorbehalt ist ja auch nur einfach ein Formalakt, der die nervt, dass er nicht so, als würde der Richter jemals,
Sag mal, hä, also wenn der Richter, ähm wer hatte das denn.
Ist Mark schon mal vorgekommen sein, dass sowas auch mal abgelehnt wurde.
Der Bundesrepublik mag es Fälle geben wo sowas mal abgelehnt wurde aber in der Regel ist es allein so dass die Ablehnung für den Richter Arbeit ist,
und die Zustimmung nicht, weil die Ablehnung muss er begründen. Das heißt, der vor ihm liegt dieser Antrag und dann hat er die Entscheidung ähm,
Haken drunter, Stempel, äh Siegel,
Abdruck vom Fingerblut oder so und Thema erledigt oder er setzt sich hin und äh nimmt ein Papier und Bleistift oder einen Füller und schreibt irgendwie ne, weil,
Ja, allein das ist ja schon der äh so,
Systemin herrent. So das heißt, das heißt, man kann eigentlich immer, wenn man so ein als als Beamter, wenn man so einen äh Antrag stellt, davon ausgehen, dass der positiv beschieden wird. Das Blöde ist nur, dass es halt ein Verwaltungsakt ist, der den, der den,
Vorgang bremst. Aber genau das oder man will ja eigentlich noch mehr, aber wenigstens das ist ja schon mal äh das Mindeste.
Ähm also insofern auf die verqueren Art und Weise hat der Mann Recht, indem er eben sagt, dass der Richter vorbehalt auch nicht sein seinen eigentlichen Zweck erfüllt. Ähm.
So, das ist jetzt so die große Kritik an der Sache. Es gibt eine sehr ausführliche Stellungnahme des AK Vorrat, die ich jedem äh ans Herz lege, die ich da auch verlinkt habe. Äh,
und ähm die der Ausblick, auf den wir hier äh schauen, wie gesagt, bis Ende Juni oder bis Juni muss das eigentlich,
muss über diesen Gesetzesentwurf entschieden sein.
In dieser Legislaturperiode noch eine Chance der Umsetzung hat.
Damit die Deadline vom äh Bundesverfassungsgericht nicht gerissen wird, ja, weil dann stehen sie auf einmal ohne Bestandsdatenauskunftsmöglichkeit da, weil sie das nach der alten Regelung nicht mehr machen dürfen,
Ja, das heißt, äh,
Es gab jetzt diesen diese Anhörung im Innenausschuss. Jetzt kann als nächstes kann dann der Bundesrat irgendwie seine Zustimmung verweigern. Wir wissen ja, also diese Anhörung, da passiert ja eigentlich nix. Die sind ja ohne also ohne,
Wirkung. Ähm das heißt jetzt gibt's dann irgendwie die das Problem oder gibt's dann die Hürde des Bundesrats? Denn das Gesetz ist Zustimmungspflichtig. Dann könnte es irgendwie in den Vermittlungsausschuss gehen,
Ja und aber die Neuregelung drängt in dem Fall und das ist also ein äh denke ich etwas,
noch zu wenig beachtetes Thema, was wir in den nächsten Monaten auf jeden Fall.
Häufiger auf den Tisch kriegen werden hier.
Ja, leider.
Ja, leider. So ist das.
Also so viel das ist da dabei geht's darum geht's bei der Bestandsdatenauskunft. Ähm so viel ich glaube so das wäre jetzt das Thema, was ich da reinwerfen wollte.
Gutes Thema. Es war auf jeden Fall im Blick behalten. Es war wieder die die klassische ähm Auseinandersetzung so aus der Kategorie Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Co, ne? Ist eigentlich immer wieder dasselbe, ne?
Finde ja auch Deutschland könnte ja mal einen Sonderpreis kriegen von irgend so einer sich um die Sprache bemühen in Gesellschaft. Allein für das Wort Bedarfsträger.
Das ist echt geil, ne? Bedarfsträger.
Die darauf. Das ist gut. Das ist richtig gut.
Das ist so, ja, wir haben da einen Bedarf, ja, das kennt jeder, das ist so äh essen ist ein Bedarf, aufs Klo gehen ist.
Auf uns den Tragen, wir mit uns rum.
Ja, ja, wir müssen da auch äh also uns muss geholfen werden, weil.
Alleine tragen.
So einen unglaublichen Bedarf, ja äh ja und wir schleppen uns hier einen ab, also.
Also das ist echt diese, also in dem Bereich, die die wollen euch vor allem, die müssen ja andauernd ähm im Prinzip neu, die müsste sich andauernd neue Begriffe ausdenken.
Falls die Alten verbrannt sind.
Ja, Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben sie ursprünglich auch mal.
Versucht umzudrehen,
Ist aber nicht so ganz gelungen. Was war nochmal die Formulierung? Was hat der hier unser Innenminister? Der hat doch versucht, da irgendwie Herr Friedrich, war das nicht gleich so nach Antritts,
nach Wiederantritt in der Auseinandersetzung mit wollte er die ganze Zeit da irgendwie einen anderen Begriff konnen. Der hat aber irgendwie überhaupt nicht verfangen,
so wenig, dass wir uns da jetzt noch nicht mal dran erinnern, das finde ich schon hart.
Ich schaue grade.
Auch, glaube ich, sehr lächerlich.
Also das neue Sprechblog hat natürlich auch schon den Begriff Vorratsdatenspeicherung behandelt.
Selbstverständlich. Ich weiß nicht, also der der Vorschlag von Friedrich war.
Ach da war dieser Gei war dieser also in dem Zusammenhang,
Äh wenn man wenn man jetzt mal so nur bei Neusprech schaut, was alles so für weitere Worte zu Vorratsdatenspeicherungen kommen. Also Kriminalität, Komma schwerste.
Funkzellenabfrage hatten wir in dem Schutzlücke war das schöne Thema, ja? Die Schutzlücke, die droht, ja.
Sind auch was ganz Schlimmes.
Mindestspeicherdauer.
Ich glaube, das war das. Eine Mindest ja ja, ich glaube, das war der Versuch, irgendwie.
Mindestdatenspeicherung. Das war das, das war das Wort, was der Hape friedlich äh da hatte, mindestens.
Das klingt nicht mal gut.
Mindest, ne? Das ist das zeigt schon direkt, diese.
Muss doch einfach mal was passieren.
Ein weiteres, wichtiges Wort in dem Zusammenhang, das nicht fehlen darf, ist grundrechtsschonend.
Das ist immer wichtig.
Ja, das wäre eher was für uns, für unsere äh.
Grundrechtsstand.
Grundrechtsschonende mediale äh Begleitung des politischen Betriebs.
Sowie umweltschonend, ne. Wird auch immer sehr viel Wert drauf gelegt, ne.
Weiß nicht, ob wie umweltschonend wir sind, aber wir sind auf jeden Fall grundrechtsschonend. Ja. Linus. Warum war's, oder?
Nee, wir haben ja gerade ein Thema übersprungen. Ja. Ja.
Jetzt kommt noch eins. Ja. Ach, du wolltest das noch anbringen? Ich dachte, du wolltest es äh auslassen.
Nee, acht, das wollte ich schon noch kurz mit reinnehmen und zwar aus äh äh persönlichen,
Aus persönlichen Gründen. Und zwar äh macht grade sehr viel Furore, die Meldung, dass sich aus Facebooks, Facebook Likes, Persönlichkeitseigenschaften vorhersagen lassen.
Vorhersagen.
Ja, also vor Vorhersagen, du benutzt den Begriff Vorhersagen, ähm in der Statistik. Deshalb, weil du quasi den, also,
in dem Moment, wo du etwas, wo es eine Korrelation gibt oder in der in dem Fall eben, also einen nachgewiesenen Zusammenhang, dann sagt das, du hast eine Vorhersagefähigkeit. Also du du sagst, du machst nicht eine Zukunft über die
Du machst keine Aussage über die Zukunft, aber du kannst dieses Merkmal quasi,
ja Vorhersagen, dass halt der, das hat der Begriff, ja.
Ich meine, was heißt das? Ich ich klicke jetzt auf so ein so ein Like äh äh Button und daraus kann man ablesen, dass ich in zehn Jahren irgendwie äh politisch dement werde oder so.
Also was sie, was sie gezeigt haben, ist ähm,
Die äh ist also eine eine Studie, die von einer Universität äh durchgeführt wurde und die haben so eine eine Facebook-App gemacht, wo dann Leute ihre Likes mit denen teilen konnten. Ja, also sie haben gesagt, so,
Die Leute konnten auf Facebook sagen, jo, gibt denen mal das, was ich auf Facebook like. Ja, und dann haben sie den außerdem haben sie den Fragebogen gegeben und haben gesagt, hier sag doch mal, äh weiß nicht, dein Geschlecht und so weiter. Ähm,
und ähm dann haben sie quasi aus den Likes,
Diese korreliert mit den Sachen, die sie im Fragebogen von den Leuten erfasst haben. Und das heißt, du hast quasi aus deren Facebook Likes, aus dem die hatten im Durchschnitt irgendwie um die hundert Likes pro Person. So quasi ein,
eine eine Matrix der Interessen dieser Person. Und diese Interessen korrelierst du wiederum mit,
Angaben, die du in dem, in dem Fragebogen von den Personen hast, ja? Und ähm da hatten sie einmal ähm Merkmale, also Geschlecht zum Beispiel, wo du sagen kannst, okay, ich bin äh,
Männlich oder weiblich waren die Antwortmöglichkeiten. Ähm.
Sehr variantenreich.
Dann irgendwie äh Homosexualität, wer so Heterosexualität so, also so,
Ähm solche Merkmale. Und dann konnten haben sie halt gesagt, okay, mit welcher Wahrscheinlichkeit können wir anhand dessen, was du bei Facebook likest, Vorhersagen, ja, ob du männlich oder weiblich bist?
Ja also so wird der.
Ziehen aus sozusagen.
So wird der Begriff in der äh in der Statistik wird halt Vorhersage so äh äh genutzt, ob du Alkohol trinkst, ob du Single bist oder in einer äh Beziehung, ja.
Nicht genannte Eigenschaften zu Tage fördern. Mhm.
Und ähm was sich jetzt herausstellt ist, und deswegen möchte ich auch so drauf eingehen. Ich habe ja genau solche Forschungen habe ich ja ein paar Jahre lang auch gemacht,
nicht mit Facebook, aber ich hab genau diese Verfahren, die sie da genutzt haben auch immer angewendet und so und das Interessante ist.
Dass sie, was jetzt immer zitiert wird, ist, sie können zum Beispiel, ob du Cocation oder African American bist? Können sie mit ähm.
Also weiß oder schwarz.
Weiß oder schwarz, können sie mit fünfundneunzigprozentiger Sicherheit zuordnen.
Ablesen aus den Likes. Ja.
So, jetzt ist das Problem, dieses Maß, was sie dafür nehmen, also diese fünfundneunzig Prozent ähm,
Dass das Maß, was sie für die Stärke des Zusammenhangs nehmen, ist also nicht ähm,
nicht adäquat. Das ist äh also wenn du wenn ich nur raten muss, bei bei zwei ähm Möglichkeiten, habe ich ja schon eine Ratewahrscheinlichkeit von fünfzig Prozent,
Dieses Maß, was sie da angeben, ist nicht bereinigt, um diese fünfzig Prozent Ratewahrscheinlichkeit.
Ja, verstehe.
Das heißt, ähm wie gesagt, ein ein Merkmal, dass mir gar keine Informationen über darüber gibt,
Mit dem würde ich immer noch fünfzig Prozent Vorhersagewahrscheinlichkeit auf dein Geschlecht haben,
Ähm und deswegen ist dieses Maß nicht adäquat. Das heißt, diese Prozentwerte, die da angegeben werden und die in jedem äh Artikel jetzt zitiert werden, sind ähm nicht angemessen.
Bei den Kategorialen Merkmalen.
Heißt, wir lernen daraus, ist alles äh.
Das ist erstmal nur eine Methodenkritik. Das ist natürlich trotzdem ein starker Zusammenhang da, ja. Also das ist aber auch jetzt nicht überraschend,
dass sich in der Lage bin zu sehen weil sich bei hundert Facebook Likes im Durchschnitt von insgesamt achtundfünfzigtausend Teilnehmern das ich dann,
Möglichkeit habe, anhand der Profile äh Männlein und Weiblein zu trennen. Interessanter ist das bei äh Homosexualität,
Äh aber auch da gibt's natürlich dann irgendwie relativ vermutlich offensichtliche Möglichkeiten,
Das zu erkennen, ja? Ähm Zigaretten rauchen, Alkoholkonsum, Drogenkonsum, ähm,
Aber da ist eben auch die der Gewinn an Aufklärung ist nicht wirklich groß. Wenn ich fünfundsechzig
Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit habe, statt fünfzig Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit habe, richtig zu liegen. Okay, also das, das so der äh methodische äh Kritik an dem einen Teil und dann haben sie das Gleiche noch gemacht mit
metrischen Merkmalen oder also mit mit Merkmalen, die auf einem Kontinum liegen. Wie zum Beispiel Intelligenz.
Was heißt das, die liegen auf einem Kontinuum?
Ähm also,
Ähm du hast du hast eigentlich drei Datenniveaus. Einmal äh kategorial, das heißt du kannst nur null, eins, zwei, drei, also du bist auf jeden Fall in einer Gruppe und nur in einer. Und zwischen diesen Gruppen gibt's nur die Relation gleich oder ungleich,
Dann gibt es ordinales Datenniveau. Das klassische Beispiel sind Schulnoten, das heißt, es gibt Gruppen,
Oder Schulnoten, eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf und es gibt die Beziehung gleich ungleich größer, kleiner. Ähm das heißt, die die Eins ist eine bessere Note als die Zwei,
aber die eins ist nicht doppelt so gut wie die Zwei oder doppelt so gut wie die drei,
sondern man kann nur größer, kleiner Aussagen machen,
Dann gibt's noch äh metrische Variablen, in denen du dann sagen kannst, äh es gibt größer, kleiner, gleich ungleich und eine ein Gleichabständigkeit dazwischen, nämlich.
Jahre Quantifizierung. Mhm.
Genau, eine Möglichkeit zu sagen, äh da gibt's ein Maß und derjenige ist, was weiß ich, äh,
so wird's halt äh der der statistischen Erwägung dazu gesehen. Aber okay und auf den hast du dann die linearen Zusammenhänge, die sie auch geprüft haben in einer Regressionsanalyse, wo dann die Stärke des Zusammenhangs ausgegeben wird und
Das ist dann ähm eine Produkt Moment-Korrelation. Ähm in dem Fall,
und die liegt jetzt bei diesen Vorhersagen auch in äh für die ganzen Persönlichkeitseigenschaften so im Bereich Punkt drei Punkt vier,
Und das sind so die übliche, im Bereich der Persönlichkeitspsychologie zu erwartenden Zusammenhangsmaße für gute für für eigentlich schwache bis mittlere Zusammenhänge,
und die die Prozentaufklärung, die ich da schaffe, ist da nicht dreißig Prozent, sondern das Quadrat der Produktkorrelation.
Bist jetzt voll in der Nerdfalle. Du musst jetzt einen Satz finden, der das alles zusammenfasst und der die Kernaussage sozusagen nochmal unterstreicht. Ohne eine Formel zu benennen.
Okay, sagen wir so, die Ergebnisse, die sie da haben, sind nicht besonders überraschend, überhaupt nicht überraschend und die Zusammenhänge sind nicht besonders stark.
Oder nicht stärker als als die Zusammenhänge, die man woanders auch erwarten würde. Nichtsdestotrotz ist es wichtig, darauf hinzuweisen, wie einfach mit anhand wie weniger,
Merkmale, nämlich in diesem Fall Webseiten, die mir gefallen. Ich,
Äh etwas über mich preisgebe, was ich eventuell verbergen möchte. Beispielsweise meine Homosexualität.
Wir sollten vielleicht mal ein CAE zu dem Thema machen, was hältst du denn davon?
Sehr gerne. Sehr, sehr, sehr gerne.
Auf jeden Fall einige Begriffe, die man, glaube ich, nochmal etwas genauer rausschälen.
Ja, ich habe, ihr habt das.
Also ich fasse es mal mit meinen Worten zusammen,
Es gab da eine Studie, um das ein großes Hallo gemacht wurde, dass man aus Facebook-Likes jetzt unheimlich viele äh Sachen herausziehen kann und der äh äh der Laie staunt und der Experte äh wundert sich, weil er irgendwie davon überhaupt nicht überrascht ist
natürlich ist das so und das sollte eigentlich auch kein wirklich überraschen aber so ist das nunmal.
Es ist es ist wichtig, darauf hinzuweisen, ja, dass eben oder das ist auch das wichtige Argument, was also Daten angeht, dass eben das Einzelne Datum, der immer,
Verhältnismäßig uninteressant ist, im Vergleich zu dem Aggregat,
Einmal über die Person, also in dem Fall halt nicht dein einer Like interessiert mich, sondern alle deine Likes und dann alle deine Likes im Verhältnis zu allen Likes von allen,
Und dann habe ich also eine Vorhersagekraft. Das heißt, die die einzelne Information ist,
wird wird exponentiell wertvoller mit je mehr anderer Information ich sie anreichere. Und dadurch steigt immer meine Vorhersagekraft.
Facebook Likes sind da etwas, was seit Jahren äh eigentlich schon erforscht ist. Und ich habe auch schon äh mal Sachen in der Richtung gemacht in einem universitären Projekt.
Gut, dann hoffe ich, dass wir hier auch Wege finden, die unsere Vorhersage äh Kraft stärken, was hier so die übliche Themenlage von Netzpolitik betrifft. Da hapert's noch so ein bisschen so. Ähm,
Solange könnt ihr ja bei uns ein bisschen auf Like äh klicken. Wir würden euch äh weniger Facebook als viel mehr Flatterplatten da legen. Das bringt einen doch weiter. Und äh da ist auch die Privatsphäre etwas besser geschützt.
Ja, aber im Moment, also da muss ich jetzt hier warnen, äh aus eurem Flatter, aus eurer Flatterhistory, kann man dann irgendwann ganz klar vorhersagen, dass ihr euch für Netzpolitik interessiert.
Kann man. Oh Gott. Ja, das stimmt.
Und zwar mit echt mit krasser Vorhersage wahrscheinlich.
Ja, aber wer da äh lieber Alufolie auf dem Kopf trägt, der kann halt dann auch die Sache auf Nonpublic äh schalten, beziehungsweise belasten. Also so ist das ja sowieso erstmal, ne.
Genau, heißt aber, dass äh flettert das immer noch dran.
Ah, du meinst, sie haben da eine Pektor in ihre eigene Cloud? Gefährlich, gefährlich, äh gefährlich. Gut.
Ich wollte noch ein kurzes Zitat zu dir. Ein ganz kurz, als dann irgendwie jemand irgendein Journalist rief dann bei Facebook an und sagte, ja ähm haben sie nicht auch hier äh gelesen, dass man da äh Sachen vorhersagen kann über die Leute aus den Likes?
Und dann sagte der Sprecher so,
ja, das finde ich jetzt nicht besonders überraschend so. Haben Sie mal überlegt, was unser Geschäftsmodell ist?
Ja.
Nein, doch. Oh.
Ah, das ist mal wieder erstaunlich, wie Leute dann doch so auf das Internet stoßen und immer wieder überrascht sind, über das Offensichtliche. Also, wäre das für den äh Offensichtliche, der oder die sich,
einfach dem, der sich ans Netz, äh, die sich schon ans Netz gewohnt hat, so, ne, also.
Aber so ist das wahrscheinlich einfach mit der Adaption neuer Technologie und Kulturform. Das äh bleibt nicht ohne Anpassungsprozesse.
Und wir sind mittendrin. Aber jetzt sind wir auch am Ende davon.
Ja, okay, ist so, ja.
Schluss ist Schluss des Anpassungsprozesses. Äh.
Ich würde sagen, wir gehen nochmal so weg für oder?
Ja, genau. Und äh wir konzentrieren uns äh aufs Wesentliche, äh wofür das Internet eigentlich da ist. Bis bald. Tschau, tschau.